[Music]
in that backfire news submitted by
backfired
you immigrated to Canada that backfired
News geo it's submitted by catnip a
reporter who exposed the man's racist
tweets was later fired after readers
found his own offensive - what an a-hole
sure [ __ ] happened at a time
cancel calls that'll never happen to me
because I'm already racist yes there you
go
I'll never call out people for their
races he'll do no don't I cook all the
time I don't say it all the time you do
I say it when I talk about the movie I
say what I talk about Korean people
really hate it oh yeah I'm a Korean
person I'm gonna turn around
Hangul no that's just Korean person in
Korean this is Korean you know where
there is nothing offensive is for
Filipinos I've never been offended by
anything I've been called [ __ ] I've
been called Buddha they say it's a clip
but this is not very offensive listen
little island person that's like honky
to me I'm like that sounds kind of like
a nice noise a lot so people are like
hey honky you like yeah yeah like a
little hot how about cracker that's my
favorite derogatory term yeah my - yes I
mean I like crack goes great with soup I
mean it doesn't sound bad to me word I
think quite low do it me like white
though or something translation yes but
it's just saying like YT but doesn't
really mean anything bad though I feel
like that fat to thing for a white how I
was when someone just goes like [ __ ]
a white person that's like the one now I
feel sure probably feel a little bit I
never feel it know or if they call you
racist that's in what context you're
white racist like you're white so
therefore your races oh yeah sure I am
that's what that's what uh
second we're all white right now Sam
Tripoli said that the worst thing you
can call a white person is racist when
they aren't a racist yeah makes racism
look like not any person that's not
racist have you called it I'm not racist
but you could call me races it doesn't
hurt my feelings yeah it's more damaging
if you say it's a white person that's
not racist and everyone just assumes
that then the word loses its meaning for
actual racist people yeah and it has man
I hear that now and I laugh half the
time at least yeah yeah I wish I had the
power to be racist I just don't have
power in this world yeah okay
so this story here when you wear those
glasses you don't look up right it's
true so this story here it's about two
guys the first one is this guy he his
name is Carson he was at this College
GameDay program ESPN's College GameDay
program and he held up a sign that said
Bush lights applied means replenished
and then he put his venmo username under
it so this is Carson right he did this
which led to him going viral to the
point where Bush like put his face on a
truck that's [ __ ] cool he started
getting a ton of donations and he said
like after he bought his beer he was
like alright the rest of this is gonna
go to a Children's Hospital
you get like a million dollars or some
[ __ ] yes exactly so then he said I'm
sane that's the power of white my friend
it's a mighty power yeah white people do
come about see I know why there's a lot
of them in America a lot of them so the
beer company and venmo said that they
would like a Twilight Zone they would
match the donation oh yeah I've been
watching that every night we're going
really anyway so um Carson he so then
that's when this other guy named Kelvin
gets into the picture
Aaron Kelvin he's a reporter for the Des
Moines Register is he the hair so he did
a piece on him like a pro he worked on a
profile for Carson who's 24 years old Oh
and that's when Aaron at the very bottom
of the this profile piece that he did on
Carson he mentioned that he did say some
racist things on his Twitter back in the
day and this is when he was 16 years old
oh but they're saying that he said this
very like oh just kind of think as a
reporter I felt like I needed to report
everything I found and if people were
donating to this cause I don't give
money to children because this guy well
he could have done as a young man is
kept all that [ __ ] money had a party
with all of his friends went to Vegas
and did some coke whatever but he chose
and he's a better that man than me cuz I
wouldn't use all that and give it to a
[ __ ] kids fun [ __ ] those kids - it's
gonna be spread between me and my
friends and we're going on a trip yeah
all right so then when Aaron reported
that he started getting a whole bunch of
death threats and like people are like
what the [ __ ] are you serious like how
are you gonna attack this person that's
trying to do something good good this
was from seven years ago I hope that guy
dies actually so then that's when people
started digging up Aaron's eyes and they
found tweets including derogatory
language against black people gay people
same-sex marriage and women there you go
there we go
yes on eight yes Aaron by the way Aaron
kelvins that's the reporter reporter yet
he looked he looks like a reporter for
sure he looks gay what no he doesn't
look like he looks like he could be a
reporter d-did but so so he's out here
trying to call him out and be a hall
monitor but he himself hears that was
was a [ __ ] he had bigoted tweets and
all that when he was a kid oh he was in
a kid when he did that how old was he
when he did those residues last month he
was 18 in high school yeah I guess
they're both kids don't do this but
anyway so then um so Aaron is saying
that he feels abandoned because the
paper that he worked at worked at gave
him two options either resign or get
fired yeah nice yeah so then he was
saying like dude that's [ __ ] up
because you guys knew like I brought
this
information to you before it published I
asked you should we even publish this
piece like of information that oh my god
I approved it exactly they approved it
up to like the head or the editor and so
he just feels like the [ __ ] dude you
guys all approve to this and then I get
I just I don't have a job anymore I
don't have his back I feel like if you
try to if you try to hold someone up up
to a standard and you better be squeaky
clean yourself but if not I don't notice
back but what he's just saying is his
team who approved it and read all of
that yeah they didn't have his back
there is no more ultimate killshot right
now in the current social media
environment than hypocrisy right yes if
you come out and say somebody did
something and then they find out you did
it you're basically social media dead
yeah like people [ __ ] wreck you
constantly about it which is funny
because we're all hypocrites right like
just wait to like you know even 10 20
years from now when people are running
for House Senate whatever the [ __ ] and
it's like hey we found your Xbox Live
account right it's gonna be nuts like
all the [ __ ] talk is recorded like know
what I'm saying like you know if that
was ever discovered
everyone's [ __ ] cuz everyone's just
being a [ __ ] head online and saying
stupid things should be fun what I hate
about this the alan is just people
there's people that are just searching
for this they're like main goal is to
just find it like to take time to
actually search through all this just to
find it they just could have left it at
okay cool cuz we were listening to Chris
Delia's podcast this more like the
driving here and he was literally
talking about the same thing how it's
weird cuz I always says it's weird yeah
so that's all is it weird that people
search they take time to search for it
to go back to that long it's [ __ ]
weird we're sure but it's like obsessive
ex-girlfriend [ __ ] I want to get to
where it's like what if you solve it
like for example the SNL guy what if you
listen to his podcast you were a fan of
his back I just it was not even that
long ago and you remember him saying
that and then you find out that he got
hired and you bring it up cuz you're
like the [ __ ] like I stopped listening
to him back then because of this reason
not that I would support that either but
I guess like that to me is a little
different then let me go dig up like
what can I find for me it all depends on
how people react and what they do
afterwards cuz on here JK news we said a
lot of crazy [ __ ] [ __ ] there's things
that we changed our perspectives on and
things like that I want to leave it all
up because that to me is a way to show
growth and humans should personal people
change you should change but in a lot of
cases people don't know how to apologize
people don't know how to change people
don't know how to self-reflect so i
think that the way that people handle
[ __ ] is what gets them fired yeah like
that one guy that was on SNL let's say
they did dig it up or if they didn't let
same as your scenario where they've
already just been listening to his
podcast and he gets called out on it he
was when he replied back on Twitter he
was using Twitter kind of like as a way
to kind of just brush it off is it oh I
guess some people just don't like my
comedy but if you really embrace it hey
that was me two years ago I'm a
completely different person now I'm so
sorry for saying that I would probably
be even a bigger fan of him yeah so the
whole thing here with Carson which is
the first guy with the sign he actually
the governor Iowa's governor made
Saturday at Carson King day because they
said you can make a mistake in your life
and still go on to do amazing things
Thank You Carson King - thank you for
reminding us all of that hashtag Iowa
proud that crazy thought now why was one
video if people can evolve yeah that's
yeah there's one video that I watched
from this truck driver who he was just a
blog of him talking and she was a former
member of the KKK and then he talks
about like his process and getting
involved and and and like why he was
afraid of you he was like why he hated
minorities is because he was afraid of
them and he was insecure and in all
these things tight yeah and then he was
like at the end of the day I think like
I was trying to prove myself but I was
just a small barking Chihuahua and I was
like oh I actually like this guy now and
I think that it doesn't matter to me
what he did like in the past if he was a
criminal or if he did anything or
whatever to me I'm like I like to see
people evolve and learn what happened
aren't there are so many pastors and
stuff that talk about how they used to
be gang member
okay and like now they're like leaders
in the community but or pastors who like
I used to [ __ ] young kids but now I
changed I think that's pretty nice don't
you all they don't
adults now my god moved from this church
and now I'm on this church and I think
that's pretty cool
did he stop the kids [ __ ] yes so you
stopped the kid [ __ ] I don't know
what you're talking about yeah I think
that's one of those things though it's
kind of hard to forgive I learned my
lesson guys I don't [ __ ] kids no more if
you say that out loud of my daughter
even with the [ __ ] even with the shame
Gillis thing right if I was like hello
everybody I'm doing stand-up tonight I
hate black people and then I'm like and
then I was like what the [ __ ] and I'm
like oh that was it's just my style I
was my joke everybody like you have a
right to [ __ ] it be like yay suck dude
that wasn't fun yeah that's all like
that's what I think gets lost in dashain
Gillison because I know a lot of comics
who are like blood em [ __ ] say
whatever and I'm down to see whatever
but we have a right to judge you too but
you all just the market is so bad yeah
there's consequences for you not
executing your joke well because in
comedy it's a it's a give and receive
like if the fans don't like it or the
people and the audience don't like it
they have the right to boo
that's an empiric ting like all you know
the comedy
[Music]